this is really exciting actually it's
great to have you on the show you killed
tonight with Bill was awesome I enjoyed
it and I just wanna know what do you
what are you drinking probably not the
water just straight whiskey I'm not sure
how much everything we drink is made of
water right yeah let's see yeah I'm
definitely curious about water and some
communities actually I feel comfortable
with tap water some communities it's
pretty obvious right out the gate
whether it's like that smells like dirt
or that looks like dirt in some
instances it's not anything that's gonna
hurt you it's just sediment floating
around but it always unnerves us is
there like a sniff test or any sort of
like purity taste that we tell people if
it doesn't smell right and if it doesn't
look right if it doesn't feel right
don't drink the water
you can probably apply that to a lot of
things oh yeah really is that simple and
I mean oftentimes I think we're waking
up to the fact that we're not gonna be
so complacent that someone says it's
okay to drink when I began my work way
back out in California 27 years ago
people were on well water and it had a
funny color to it was actually the
chromium six and they drank it because
if that was in the mineral sounds like
it'll build your bones and do absolutely
I can't hurt you but people are getting
more and more savvy to that and I think
people are asking more and more
questions and I think that people are
relying
your own instinct and if you're
uncertain you don't drink I do drink a
lot of bottled water I know that makes
some people mad because of their
plastics and things like that sometimes
I do drink the tap water I feel better
with some filtration systems that our
tap water is safe I'd like to think that
a lot of times our municipalities are
trying to do the best job that they can
right there careful about over
chlorination and the floor means in West
Virginia what just happened there was a
major pollutant and they shut it down
the problem became when they opened it
up they sent all the pollution out right
and people at that point need to be very
vigilant and water filters short showers
and here in this scenario then look
right down Snow White good call I want
to when you go and visit a town that's
maybe been experiencing you know people
get in touch with you through your
website and you go and visit someplace
I'm sure all the companies that have
been polluting just are on the best
behavior all of a sudden right
they know they know you're coming do you
announce your presence when you're there
and you're trying to bring that oh yes
it's the media's around them they know
I'm there then the companies would know
that I'm there sometimes they're really
good and they'll be very important with
sometimes they get busy hiding hiding
hiding and or they'll just find out it
morning and they want to just skew their
propaganda that this is silliness we
will tell you a story
the waters safe and again we see time
and time again what's playing out in
West Virginia happening across the board
you release the water you say it's safe
but here comes the oh [ __ ] moment 1215
two years later we were wrong you
shouldn't drink water we've got to be
Tomomi clean your room and then she
opens the closet no that's not a stop
you know it used to be that we'd almost
I don't want to say laughs but we were
so frustrated sometimes that's all you
can do what can people do from a hold
these companies accountable or should
they be electing officials that will do
that for them there's a lot they can I
see communities in fracking for instance
they've gotten very involved and they go
to their City Council meetings now I've
been to a couple where you have you
everything you see because there's so
much fun you guys they're talking to
themselves right and suddenly 1000 and
2000 community members show up they're
like boys I think people feel powerless
and they're not you elect people in make
it your job make it your business to
find out who they are what they're doing
what they stand for
make it your business to go to City
Council meetings and to stand up for
what it is you believe it and I have
actually seen time and time again in
communities across the board when they
do that
things change were involved here in
Carson California was shell and a big
pollution kids can't even go out and
play in their yard because of all the
benzene contamination they repeatedly
went to City Council meetings City
Council finally responded City Council
finally said of the waterboard you're
getting no more passes you're gonna
start cleaning this up they got the
attention in the mayor and the mayor's
now passing resolutions to make this
happen
nice work nice work yeah see so power to
the people they can still make a change
they just have to start believing that
they can I know that sounds like oh you
know believe rah-rah but it's really
true we've gotten complacent as people
and we think that our leaders whoever
they may be are the one set are gonna
come save the day
well guess what you know Superman's not
coming it's time for us to start saving
our own asses we'll get out there make
it your business and you know thank you
for making it your business I'm really
appreciate and see you next time